dans le nord et dans le pas de calais
les violents orages ont d'abord touché
le littoral avant de progresser vers
l'intérieur des terres
de nombreuses routes et des dizaines de
maisons ont été inondées les intempéries
ont également détruit une partie d'un
gros élevages de volailles ne
correspondant dans la région marianne
masse et dominique maes était sur le
terrain des inondations durant toute la
nuit
je veux on peut l'arrêter l'eau on la
subit on peut que la regarder passer
gold il aura suffi d'une une heure
pendant laquelle il a plu autant que
tout un mois du mai les syndicats n'ont
pas résisté les quelques survivants
partir anti à l'équarrissage dès demain
lisa bibelots et puis qui sait sourire
quand ils ont de l'eau pas les gros lots
irrécupérable de la cèze ville bilan
trois cent cinquante mille francs des
peines ça a commencé par des éclairs des
coups de tonnerre
les égouts qui sentent plus forts et
puis l'eau qui monte tout ne s'arrête
plus l'eau est arrivée carrément tous
les côtés même par les placards quand on
a évacué
ici on a été obligé de me tenir pour
pouvoir passer tellement tellement le
lot était force
cette huile et entier de la région
auront détecté près de 500 interventions
et mise en sécurité des biens surtout
les personnes dont aucune victime
personne mais c'est la boue qui rentrait
dans les habitations et les gens prient
de palets pris de peur dans plus d'une
centaine de maisons l'eau la boue ont
tout balayé sur leur passage
c'est mon père qu'à l'intérieur a l'air
d'aimer qui on va tomber sur parpaing
congélateur con ce qu'on veut plus faire
par chance les intempéries n'auront fait
aucune victime mais parfois des dégâts
impressionnants comme cette boulangerie
transpercé par une coulée de boue mais
pétanque et des appareils il faut une
tonne une top 5
tout est arrivé c'est au bras de m ils
sont dépassés de neuf aujourd'hui il va
falloir tout remettre en état faire
passer les assureurs et tenter de
comprendre comment un orage comme tant
d'autres peut provoquer autant de dégâts